The Joe Rogan Experience if you could go
back if you go back at any point in time
see how people were living oh
just be like in an invisible bulletproof
bubble yeah you could just exist and
watch and no one would know you were
there oh that'd be fun if you were like
1890s no danger yeah
dinosaurs no danger yeah anything
whatever you want whatever 30s Germany
now uh occupy occupied France
Occupy Wall Street I'd be like this is
so quaint yeah little you guys know
what's coming
sorrow
yeah yeah you're you are in Another
Universe okay you're you exist in
another dimension you're you're in a
dimensional sphere that's allowing you
to take place without you can't be
interacted with nothing can touch you
impossible middle-aged [__]
middle-aged horse were eight back then
he died
[Laughter]
a book called The Great mortality by
John Kelly I was looking at is [__]
crazy the king of England showered three
times in three months and that was a
scandal everyone was like this
[__] is using up the water he
thinks he is something else right one
shot it was rare to change your clothes
once a year yeah well that's what they
said about the Mongols at their clothes
because there was animals they were
literally yeah rats living literally rot
off of them wow
rotting off with them there's two places
I would go there I would want to see
Genghis Khan take over like cities sure
I would like to see that I'd love to see
somebody being a pole Pot Village right
before he comes [__] like that yeah
imagine the [__] smell then that's
Louis XIV was terrified of bathing he
said to have taken only three baths in
his life
Louis took the trend for perfumery to
new heights by uh
commissioning is perfumer to create a
new scent for each day of the week
oh it was thought that water spread
disease so the less you obeyed the less
vulnerable you were she probably did wow
yeah
wow
[__] into holes in the ground and
not washing their [__] cities were
just same water everyone throwing their
[__] out of their [__] window right
dude no Plumbing slaughtered houses
everywhere everywhere they're detailed
when people were like at the beginning
of the turn of the century in America
and what it was like in like the early
1900s in America yes cities yeah they
couldn't get food up to them it's
horrible yeah like do you think like
Amazon's dropping off your produce no
like back then no one's dropping off
Jack's [__] you living in the city no
one's growing anything that's it
terrible
article called the disgusting history of
Royal palaces hell yeah just the very
like first thing
because I have so much human waste that
was accumulating oh
they actually did escape the disgusting
messes large Royal parties produced
Palace is like Henry's Hampton Court had
to be constantly evacuated so they could
be cleaned of the accumulated mounds of
human waste no Plumbing livestock and
farmland also needed time to recover
after supplying food for so many people
once the tour was over Henry in a
swelling Court of over a thousand would
keep moving for the rest of the year
traveling frequently between the king's
60 residences in a vain attempt to live
in hygienic surroundings
so he just kept [__] in all his
different houses
I've been in there [__] eating poop
for 12 years we gotta move
these [__] people didn't know not to
just [__] in your house he's your
hoarder he just kept moving you don't
want to go outside this room's done you
go outside you might get hit with an
arrow right just shitty [__] in the
balance yeah so there's a million Jason
Voorhees is outside
oh my God the hallways would be come so
caked with Grime and soot from constant
fires that they were fairly black the
very Crush of the Court members was so
dense that it made a thorough house
cleaning impossible and futile though
cleanliness standards were subpar
throughout the the Medieval Renaissance
and Regency eras Royal courts were
typically dirtier than the average small
cabin our home I'll be honest Europe
still [__] stinks dude
I was just there last week oh
it's the worst I'm not doing great are
they noticeably
um
they're thinner but I'm saying the UK is
catching up UK's got some chips on our
heels yeah really fast 10 years 20 years
ahead of them there we go all the fast
food and [__]
they're gross like pasty and red there's
nothing wrong with being pasty red and
fat
some people like it dude some girls like
it all right
but yeah you know they said in Old New
York they'd have to they had a a company
that would just move dead horses on the
road because horses would just die and
they just leave it there what are you
gonna push it in a dumpster oh Jesus who
paid for that taxes [__] everywhere yeah
oh horseshit everywhere but it's like an
old car that just breaks down you just
leave it and by the way imagine living
in a whole city that's filled with
people who took a [__] boat from
Europe everybody's a gambler dude
everyone's a game those are wild folks
Ellis Island that might not get there
might not get there just for the chance
how much do you really know about what's
over there yeah nothing somebody lied to
you at a bar and yeah
and then you show up and you're like
what is this black guy of a [__]
we're into war with Italians here
they're gonna meet them you gotta shoot
at other irish guys right away weird oh
yeah the Donner party like let's take a
chance
grandpa just died just keep walking
should we go next year ah we gotta go
this year yeah there's something over
there Curiosity how many people have
they talked to that made that Journey
before them yeah was there anybody no a
couple the one guy was like I know a
better way the guide oh the guy
you've got to leave by March and they're
like late maze still works
um
oh no they just assumed something was
over there
yeah they're kind of guessing they would
eat like leather and [__] yeah just
boiling [__] the whole time well in
the back of those wagons they were all
[__] they would have kids they'd have
kids really yeah there's nothing to do
you're just stuck in the back of a wagon
wheel they split up one of the two
parties had one [__] ax for firewood
and they were swinging it and then the
[__] ax handle just flew off 200
yards into the snow and they were like
we're all dead yeah he couldn't find it
it was gone what yeah they had to leave
lot of trees on fire
do you read that book under the the
indifferent stars above no we're just
nearby there oh really all the history
is everywhere they found when they found
them they were like snow the snow drifts
were so big that they were in pits of
like 20 feet of snow they would like the
people the the rescue people found them
they would like look in the pit they'd
see someone just like yeah eating humans
oh
he's pit this person's dead not to
mention some [__] choctaws coming at
you with a face painting
yeah no they said yeah they had a couple
of Indian guides and then they saw them
looking at them like drumsticks in those
cartoons
Sacagawea sack lunch